Dos jóvenes comenzaron su viaje en
Bitcoin el año pasado. Uno trabajaba 12
horas al día mirando gráficos y
persiguiendo cada vela verde. Anoche,
una sola trampa de ballenas borró toda
su cuenta. El otro hombre pasó la noche
con su familia, tomó un café y despertó
con una ganancia de $5,000.
La diferencia no fue la suerte, fue el
sistema.
Uno estaba cazando, el otro estaba
defendiendo.
La mayoría de los traders fallan porque
piensan que el trading se trata de
comprar. No es así. Se trata de no caer
en las trampas. En el mercado de BTC
está siendo casado por instituciones.
Sin un escudo, tus emociones se
convierten en tu peor enemigo.
Sientes el FOMO, haces clic en comprar y
la trampa se cierra.
Trap Defense BTC lo cambia todo. Nuestro
motor visualiza las trampas invisibles
de las ballenas. Te enseñamos la
habilidad más poderosa del mundo, la
disciplina de no hacer nada el 70% del
tiempo. Cuando finalmente te mueves, lo
haces con un 90% de certeza.
Es una defensa de alta resolución para
un mercado de alto riesgo. No seas el
trader que lo pierde todo. Sé el que
permanece protegido.
Activa tu protocolo de defensa a
continuación.
Bienvenido a la academia. M.